I i really enjoy our there's there's a
mass of the daily coverage which is and
this is another point that people you
know like to debate that what is
political writing too focused on the
horse race the who's up who's down who's
raised the most money and I think to
some extent I think that's a very
natural kind of reporting I think it
gives the the beat reporters a framework
and I also think you know that's that's
a very large part of the political
process you know who's up and who's
damning who who's raising more money I
mean money is just a reflection of how
much that message is resonating and so I
have no problem with that that type of
coverage the coverage that I like is the
or that I feel illuminates the
candidates in a deeper sense or the the
pieces that step back and and either
explore a theme or get deeper access to
a candidate that takes you beyond the
daily the just the sort of the constant
messaging that happens in a in a
campaign and really tries to explain in
a deeper sense what the candidate who
they are as a person how their campaign
is a reflection of their their their
their sort of deeper self so you have
it's interesting you know it's hard to
it's hard to know i mean i think i have
a very i have a biased sample because
living in New York and and having a lot
of friends who are journalists i think
i'm somewhat in the media bubble but I I
know from my own just my own experience
the pieces that stick with me long after
you know I've read is everything I can
about the daily coverage or the you know
the the deeper more probing longer
pieces
you